faith is taking the first step even when
you don't see the whole staircase dr.
King said more than 50 years ago it's
beautiful
president Trump showed good faith last
week in that bipartisan meeting where he
allowed the cameras in for almost an
hour as they discuss Dhaka and
immigration and although he didn't see
the entire staircase leading to the
final agreement
he told Democrats and Republicans all of
them that were present what he needed to
get to yes he needed an end to chain
migration and the wall in exchange for a
path to legalization for those 800,000
illegal immigrants two days later the
Democrats acting in bad faith along with
Lindsey Graham presented him a deal that
they knew he couldn't accept it
increased chain migration and did not
sufficiently fund the wall a total
non-starter so after the president nixed
it Senator Durbin rushed out to mix
mischaracterize off-color remarks about
the corruption in the third world that
drives citizens of those countries away
into the United States will that set off
a firestorm everyone from Al Sharpton
deliver on James wade in declaring Trump
toxic on the issue of race and then
despicable columns like this further
poison the well yeah I love that new
ounce by Charles blow members of the
Congressional Black Caucus predictably
are piling on I've called him a racist
deplorable despicable added to what
others are calling him a [ __ ]
ignorant on and on and on do you think
President Trump is a racist I think he
is a racist now if I were a conspiracy
theorist and watching how this whole
thing is played out I'd almost want to
say the entire thing was a setup let's
talk about what's really going on here
the Democrats cannot afford for Trump to
be successful particularly among African
Americans unemployment among African
Americans was 7.9 percent in 2016 last
month
it was down over a point to 6.8%
that's a record weekly earnings for
African Americans up nearly 2% home
ownership among African Americans has
ticked up to 42 percent given the
success of Trump's policies for black
America and the left's tragic record
they've decided to demonize the
president as a racist it's all they have
disturbin Durbin went so far as to claim
that the president was racist for using
the term chain migration when it came to
the issue of quote chain migration I
said to the president do you realize how
painful that term is to so many people
African Americans believe that they
migrated to America in Chains and when
you speak about chain migration it hurts
them personally well then we found this
the DREAM Act would not allow what is
known as chain migration in fact DREAM
Act students would have very low limited
ability to sponsor their family members
yeah it's when Trump uses that it's
racist when he uses that it's just
descriptive and incidentally Lindsey
Graham who supposedly uprated the
president for calling certain countries
s holes had no trouble using his own
tough language when referring to certain
countries the people coming across the
southern border live in Hill holes they
don't like that they want to come here
our problem is we can't have everybody
in the world who lives in a hellhole
coming to America oh how rude so our
Grandma Durban races if we apply the
same logic they want us to apply to
Trump well I guess they are
that's ridiculous of course the left is
now circling the wagons on this and now
we learn that John Lewis Maxine Waters
Frederico wilson member with the cowboy
hat and a few others our board cutting
the State of the Union but you got to be
kidding me
they should all be attending to thank
the president for all he's doing to
better the lives of African Americans on
my radio show today author and Hoover
Institution Fellow Shelby Steele
had these choice words for congressman
Lewis John Lewis's is Kant lacks the
imagination and has been so well
rewarded for his history of protest that
he just keeps beating that drum he keeps
trying to protest thinking that that's
what's gonna get us ahead it's not
protest is over for black Americans we
have to we have to rely on the
individual developing their skills their
talents competing in the world
now if the congressional Democrats and
celebs in the fields of entertainment
and sports if they really wanted help
struggling minorities they would work
with not against President Trump to
continue to expand economic and
educational opportunities like school
choice for all people but thankfully I
was actually heartened by this
congresswoman Sheila Jackson Lee has not
announced plans that she'll join the no
shows at the State of the Union now
let's be real it would take a nuclear
holocaust for her to give up that camera
ready real estate she always occupies on
the aisle if she already they're camped
out she has to come on the show I'd like
to think she's fun I like her as usual
regular working people tend to have a
better handle on the truth than the
swamp dweller dwellers here in
Washington I want you to listen to a few
of my callers for my show today we are
doing much better under President Trump
than we did when we tell it on our own
person so to speak President Obama he
did very little directly to help our
community we thought when we elected him
he would indeed do it Donald Trump is
doing make America great
instead he divided America Trump is not
a racist guy you know Trump is trying to
equality for American you know and and
somehow everybody's think all these
solar H's always it's a racist coming
and he's not he just want what's best
for Americans black white or other
that's I love radio hear from real
people everyday it's it's my own phone
this group ongoing it's pretty obvious
why the Democrats have themselves so
worked up into this racial frenzy they
are petrified of a Republican president
who actually delivers tangible economic
results for black and Hispanic Americans
Democrats are racial monopolist and
they're not about to allow President
Trump to break their stranglehold on the
black and Hispanic voters without a
really nasty fight which is what you're
seeing right now now check this out the
Atlantic is reporting that the
president's support among African
Americans is up that's the Atlantic
magazine it's not a conservative
think-tank in fact by the way that's
support among African Americans has
nearly doubled when he was elected back
in 2016 only 13% of black men supported
Trump now according to a new survey of
more than 600,000 people Trump's support
among African American men is up to 23%
he's also gone up somewhat with black
women from 4% that's a pathetic number
in 2016 too now a little bit better 11%
in this latest poll I'm telling you this
as the financial benefits of Trump's
policies touch the pocketbooks and the
neighborhoods of the black community the
old Democratic charges and hysteria will
look more and more unhinged now is this
really what dr. King dreamed about faith
freedom an equal opportunity we're at
the heart of dr. King's vision for his
fellow Americans and fellow black
Americans and today who's closer to
helping more of our citizens realize
that vision President Trump who in a
year has already shown incredible
results or Democrats who when they're
out of power and out of ideas simply
call their opponents racists I think you
know the answer and that's the angle